grandes rasgos cómo lee estos resultados
tan positivos para el actual Primer
Ministro
Muchas gracias por la invitación fue de
resultados que esperaba ha repetido más
o menos el porcentaje que obtuvo en las
elecciones de mayo Pero esta vez con un
sistema electoral mayoritario que
permite a nuevas democracia el partido
de derechas obtener como comentó una
mayoría en el parlamento y le pido como
ha afectado al resultado del actual
Primer Ministro que va a repetir mandato
episodios que han pasado recientemente
como el naufragio frente a las costas
griegas de hace dos semanas también el
accidente de tren de hace unos meses la
situación económica del país
todo fuera de la situación económica del
país parece que muy poco la mayoría de
los votantes han premiado el gobierno
por el crecimiento económico del país y
parece que muchos votantes no prestan
mucha atención a la tragedia de los
trenes o el naufragio de los migrantes y
por otro lado Cómo explica la debacle de
la izquierda particularmente del
proyecto de siritza liderada por el ex
Primer Ministro Alexis
hay muchos votantes que están rechazando
el pedido de chicas en el gobierno tanto
por Herodes en la política económica
como con el acuerdo sobre el nombre del
país
de vecinos de macedonia del Norte y
ahora hay una lucha en el centro y en la
izquierda entre Quién va a obtener esos
votos de sirisa han entrado muchos
nuevos pequeños partidos en el
parlamento
uno de izquierdas de su antigua
presidente del parlamento recostando
pulu pero han entrado también dos nuevos
partidos de extrema derecha uno
religioso y uno que padece ser apoyado
por los neonazis de oro dorada y
precisamente profundicemos en esto en la
extrema derecha y en los neonazis de
Alba dorada de amanecer dorado como
decimos también en español que la
justicia griega llegó a calificar de
organización criminal Cómo se explica su
resistencia digamos la resistencia de
esta ideología en Grecia
Exacto pues Los títeres están en la
cárcel pero desde la cárcel han apoyado
un nuevo partido que se llama espartanos
que ha entrado en el en el parlamento
parece que como pasa en muchos en muchas
sociedades europeas a la sociedad griega
también está pasando por una etapa de
crecimiento del voto a la extrema
derecha de derechazo a la inmigración y
ahora el total del voto de la extrema
derecha es igual de alto o incluso Más
alto que era en los años de la crisis de
la deuda y evangelios le pregunto a
nivel de Unión Europea qué tal se leen
desde Bruselas estos resultados como una
estabilidad positiva digamos
depende del partido el partido popular
donde pertenece nueva democracia
definitivamente positivo Pero hay voces
como dentro de Grecia tanto en Bruselas
que son muy críticas del gobierno
democracia sobre temas de Estado de
derecho hubo un escándalo de escuchas
telefónicas De oposición y también de la
política migratoria Entonces es una
batalla sobre qué Debería ser no solo la
política griega sino la política europea
en esos temas